GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME IN
ANTICIPATION OF A SUBCOMMITTEE
OR MEETING I WANT TO START WITH
SOME OF THE HOUSEKEEPING STUFF-
I'D LIKE TO CONVENE I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE ROOM
OVERALL REMOTE- MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED
WE'RE PRACTICES SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND WEAR A MASK AT
ALL IMES HERE IN THE ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING.
SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED AMOUNT OF PEOPLE IN
PERSON. HAVE A FEW OPTIONS FOR
WITNESSING TESTIMONY TODAY. IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND
I'LL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME ALL ASK THE PUBLIC NOT TO
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE IN
ADDITION. TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE ROOM
WITNESSES MAY MAKE USE OF YOUR
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
LOCATED NORTH SIDE OF THE
CAPITOL. FOR CALLING WITNESSES
WE WILL ALSO BE USING MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICES THROUGH A
WINDOW THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS IN A REPEAT TWICE.
844-721-7239 EIGHT FOUR FOUR
SEVEN TWO ONE. SEVEN TWO THREE
NINE AND THE ACCESS CODE IN OUR
REPEAT TWICE IS. 284-371-3154
THIRTY SEVEN IT ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
COMMUNICATIONS A CONVEYS
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS WELL AS
THE TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON ITS BEGINNING AND
IT. FIGHT IF YOU ARE CALLING
IN. PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING FOR IS ON AT THE
BEGINNING OF THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. IF YOU'RE HAVING
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATE
PHONE SERVICE. YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT 916-319-2637 OR
PETE THAT AGAIN NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE. TWO SIX THREE
SEVEN. AT ON OUR TEAM WILL BE
THERE TO HELP YOU. WILL ALSO
ACCEPT ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY. TO THE POSITION
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. AS WE PROCEED WITH THE
WITNESSES. AND PUBLIC TESTIMONY
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS THAT THE
ASSEMBLY HAS RULES TO ENSURE
THAT WE MAINTAIN AND RUN AN
EFFICIENT AND FAIR HEARING.
COME ON. HELLO THERE.
WE'RE
WE'RE BEGINNING TO BE A
COMMITTEE AS A SUB COMMITTEE
UNTIL WE STOP US RECORDS LET'S
BEGIN WITH ITEM ONE A. B. SEVEN
E. FOR THIS BECAUSE PERCENT.
THANK YOU AS MISTER CHAIR
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY FOUR IS A
STRAIGHT PORT MEASURE THAT WILL
MODERNIZE AND IMPROVE ACCESS TO
THE CALIFORNIA LIFELINE
PROGRAM. THIS WILL IMPROVE THE
RENEWAL PROCESS THAT CURRENTLY
HEAVILY RELIES ON MAILING
DOCUMENTS TO ENROLLEES IN IN
TURN REQUIRING CUSTOMERS TO
FILL OUT MAIL BACK THE
DOCUMENTS OR COMPLETE THE
PROCESS ONLINE. THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
CONTINUE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THEIR LIFELINE SERVICE WITHOUT
HAVING TO NAVIGATE. AN ARCHAIC
AND BURDENSOME PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. WE'RE YEP. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE A QUORUM A MATTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SANTIAGO. PATTERSON
BOERNER HORVATH YOUR BRIAN
CERVANTES. DAVIES EDUARDO
GARCIA HOLDEN. LOW HERE COOK
SILVA. RODRIGUEZ BALLADARES
WEBER. THANK YOU ABOUT. THANK
YOU WE HAVE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES- TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION OF THE
OF THE BILL NOW WILL MOVE THE
PUBLIC COMMENTS UNLESS I MADE A
WILL AWARE OF FROM THE
SERGEANTS DIFFERENTLY. BUT A
PROCEED. THE PUBLIC COMMENTS IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM. IT APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE OUT SEEING NONE IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THE RTS
ROOM. SERGEANT THE- FOR
MODERATOR IF THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE. AND
LATER JUMPEDON THE PHONE LINE
TO BE LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION. IF SO
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
BUT WE DO HAVE ONE IN OUR QUEUE.
THIS IS A NAME FOR THE BUSINESS
OF POSITION ONLY. IT WILL GO TO
NUMBER TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS
I'M ABOUT AND THAT'S WHAT THE
WAY TO MAKE GROUP ON BEHALF OF
TO CONNECT WORK. THANK YOU.
MODERATES ARE THE ONLY ONE. AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO OTHERS
PLEASE CONTINUE. WELL MOST OF
THE SECOND- THE MOTION IS A
SEVEN AMENDMENTS TO BE
CONCURRED. ANY CLOSING COMMENTS.
I HAD A QUESTION. YEAH ON THE
LIFELINE I KNOW THAT TIME SOME
OF US KNOW WHAT THAT IS BUT ON
MANY PEOPLE IN THE PUBLIC DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THAT IS SO IF
YOU CAN KIND OF JUST. TELL US
ABOUT THE- LIFELINE IS- LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS RIGHT TO.
HAVE A PHONE. FRANKLY IT'S
ADMINISTERED THROUGH THE CPUC-
PEOPLE SIGN UP THERE ISN'T
RENEWAL PROCESS AND CURRENTLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING IS PEOPLE ARE
DROPPING OFF DURING THE RENEWAL
PROCESS BECAUSE IT'S ONEROUS
BUT THOSE SAME CUSTOMERS END UP
RE SIGNING UP FOR LIFELINE SO
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO MAKE THIS
MORE SEAMLESS AND ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE CAN STAY- WHO QUALIFY
CAN STAY ON MY PHONE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THEN OF COURSE
ISN'T COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I SEE
NINE- MATT SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS WITH
RECOMMENDATION THAT SENATE
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO I
PATTERSON. BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH I'M BRIAN
CERVANTES CERVANTES I'D DAVIS
DAVIS I EDUARDO GARCIA HOLDEN
HOLDEN I'D LOW LOW- I COOK
SILVA COOK SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ SIGH CALAVERAS
VALLADARES SIDE WEBER. WEBER I.
ZERO SIX. CAN ZERO MEASURES OUT.
EDVARD CHARGES PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU. YEAH
BUT IT REALLY WELL I THINK THAT
THAT WOULD BE FINE. ONE OF THE.
THIS CALL ROLE. YEAH WHAT CAN
TO DO YEAH HI.
ZERO ELEVEN
ZERO. THERE ARE A LOT.
HOW THIS
IS A. SEE IF HE IS INJURED.